for any entrepreneur who wants to to go
in i would just say ask people love to
talk about what they do really all you
have to do is ask and you'll be
surprised how much people would love to
sit down with you and tell you what
they're doing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
today's episode is all about real estate
and innovation meet ziv show the country
manager of jll israel
zev is responsible for jll's activities
in israel expanding its business and
client base he develops and manages
strong working relationships with
clients and executive management teams
throughout the world ziv is a commercial
real estate prop tech and tech expert
with over 15 years of international
experience having worked in the us emea
and aipac successfully delivering
projects and sales of critical
initiatives for global clients through
operational excellence and client
management
i'm really excited because i don't need
to talk about prophetic enough
construction tech and real estate even
though you know this is the world we
live in this is these are the houses
that we're in the four walls around us
we're walking down the street whether
it's in china thailand united states
israel or europe the world is
changing rapidly suburbs to cities to
suburbs you know we have drones flying
around us changing the way we're going
to be interacting with with both
construction but also our daily lives
and i'm confused because i have no idea
really where we're at and you know as an
investor and in the startup ecosystem i
feel like i need to understand this
better and so i'm really thankful that
you're here thank you sure my pleasure
and you know it's interesting you you're
raising this issue you know
when
when i start my lectures to my students
i always give the example of the empire
state building
and and i started asking them do you
know how long it took to build the
emperor's dead building
and the question is and the answer is
slightly over two years
around the 1930s or something like that
and then i asked them well how long
would you think it will take to build
today the empire state building
and it's not gonna take less it's clear
to us all you know we can argue if it's
gonna take three years four years
permitting you know
changes in some of the standards but
basically we all understand we haven't
moved a lot since the 1930s
and then i tell them okay look at the
other areas take computing
take health you know take aviation take
almost any other
area in the world and think where that
has progressed you know in the last
century or so
and
and when you start thinking about it the
largest industry in the world is real
estate
and it hasn't moved anywhere
and and and this this is how you how
usually i start most of my
a a conversation with people when we
start talking about proptech it's about
we're we're dealing with
probably the largest
the most
um
i would say the richest or the one that
has the most funds
flowing into it the most polluting
in
industry in the world
a about
i think 30 percent of the world energy
and about 40 percent of a carbon
emission in the world
go through real estate
and yet
nothing has changed
in centuries in the way we build our
homes in the way we deliver projects
it's all there so so i i think this is
this is a great starting point to start
even talking about prop tech about
innovation about to you know what what's
going on in the world of real estate
today in this manner
so i have a simple but
the most complicated question why
you know this is something that we
experience every single day
why are we still in the same capacity we
were at in the 1930s
so so so you know for a simple question
it's a complicated answer
because of many reasons i think first of
all because
there's too much money in it as is so
there's no need for change people didn't
really feel
like
you know the first step in
in
doing a change is when people
feel like a change must happen
and and
people today are still happy to live or
who are happy to live with the same home
they were living or a you know going to
the same office that their parents went
to 20 or 30 years ago
and and
now
things have changed you know but up
until now i think i think you know this
this was part of the reasons why why
things didn't change
it's also a conservative industry
a
it's also very fragmented industry
so it's
it's very hard to be in a position where
you know you've seen under under
industries that
you know things like winner takes all or
things like that
right it doesn't really
it's it's very hard to do it in an
industry like real estate
right and so
if we're looking at you not coming from
a software side and then you know i'm
used to ohm's law and you know the
exponential rapid change and
and being able to deploy fast and if
we're looking now at the way technology
intersects with real estate
where are we at today in 2022
are things are things shifting is the
needle moving
is the tech ecosystem making its way
into real estate in a really meaningful
way
i think realistically
we're on the verge of it's happening i
don't think it happened yet
i think everyone knows disruptive
technology is coming to to real estate
but no one knows
where
or how or or when
and and this is what this is what makes
it so exciting because everyone now are
like
are searching for for the next back
big thing you know it's it's like but no
one knows what it's going to be so
so it's
i think
slightly immature
environment it's not like you know when
you speak with cyber security guys or or
fintech
there's so many
companies or ideas that already made it
but on proptech not a lot when you think
about it not a lot of companies really
you know were able to make it an impact
so suzie but but here i'm i'm as a young
entrepreneur i'm sitting here and i'm
thinking well okay there are so many
different things that i can optimize
from the way that the bricks are being
transferred to the building to the 3d
mapping of the building while it's being
constructed to the way to different
financial services and investment
strategies why is it so hard for me as
an entrepreneur to break into the
proptech market
so
again a lot of reasons okay i'll start
with
that
a lot of the things require hardware to
a certain degree
not like a software engineer so and and
as soon as you start delivering building
things or or you're starting to depend
on supply chain
uh
the growth rates for this type of
companies are very different and you
know if you get something wrong
on the software you got a bug
and you you can you can if you're really
good you can someone even to get someone
to pay you for the bug that you've made
in your software
and
when you design something wrong in a
building
and and a beam falls on someone's head
it's a completely different story
so so
so it's it's
it's more difficult i would say to to
scale up
it's more difficult to show you know the
a
the return rates or or you know growth
and things like that which which still i
think today to the investors
it's it's becoming it's not something
they they fully grasp and understand how
they can make money out of it
i think that makes sense yet you still
teach real estate entrepreneurship so
what what is
what is real estate entrepreneurship in
essence so in an asset is a
you know i also work in jl and you know
our slogan is shaping the world of real
estate for a better world
and and i think i think that summarize
it
also when we talk about proptech
as i said
it's it's about
you know
uh environmental becoming a big issue
now and and and how the world is
changing it's about
uh dealing with uh
the how how the the workplace is gonna
look like it's it's we're talking about
our cities are changing uh how how the
regulation is is going to change the
world
in these manners we're talking about a
esg environmental social governance and
how that's going to come
into play
in so so i think all of it together when
we talk about real estate
entrepreneurship we're talking about how
can you come with the right ideas
things that will make an impact
a
both on the technological side
but i will also say you know on on other
aspects uh like like i just mentioned
it's it's not just about
coming
build something that's going to give us
tons of money and let's you know we'll
all be happy with that it's not enough
these days
so what where do the motivations lie
today if we're looking at most real
estate projects that most real estate
you know
uh
entrepreneurial activities around the
world where where is what what is the
deep word of the motivation is it mainly
financial assets is that really the main
motivator for real estate today
so
no actually the the motivator for for
a real estate today is is the occupiers
people are looking on people
if if you take
any company today
it
spends most of of its money on on
salaries
basically and and and so so it's always
an issue of productivity if you can
provide people the the the most
productive environment the most
supportive environment
if people can you know do the right
brainstorming or or that that's that's
that's
that's the focus and when when that's
your starting point and you start going
backwards and saying how can i do it how
can i design a space that does it how
can i give people the right environment
how can i find the right amenities to to
aim that will provide these services and
then how can i construct a building that
that will have these capacities how can
i i make i'll make people want to go to
that place that's that's that's what
people are looking for so i think
the end is is the people and then start
going backwards towards the construction
towards the prop deck that's that's the
way to look at it
okay i i get it and then and
walk me through this understand this you
know a feeling and
and understanding of yours that we're on
this verge so what i'm hearing from you
is that we're at this inflection point
where
where we've built substantial technology
and expertise in a variety of fields and
we're about to find this integration
with proptech what is this going to
what's going to happen so if we're
looking at the world or the way real
estate is is constructed and sold in
let's say five years
how are things going to change because
of this verge that we're on
wow
you know it's very difficult to
prophesize how it's gonna look
uh
but we are seeing things you know there
are concepts like digital twins that are
coming into play
uh the metaverse is of course now a big
thing all over the world and so
metaphors and and and real estate go
hand in hand
because that the fact that you can start
creating this kind of of a
real i would say even augmented reality
uh indoor navigation for example is is a
huge thing that people are trying to
find a solution for
and
i i saw companies that that now have
technologies you go in and and you're
looking i don't know to buy a nike shoe
then uh you can go in and you'll just it
will you'll see a token on ahead of you
and you'll just walk through the store
that has it and it's automatically
connected to the inventory that they
have in the shop and things like that
so i think i think that's going to be a
big change i think that the materials
that we construct building from
are going to be completely different i
think the way we construct a
a lot of work is being done on a
how can we expedite construction
activities
a precast for example or or things like
that is is
people have been trying to do it for a
very long time
but it seems like you know moving into
more modernization and things like that
may be
something that will be mature enough
these days
so if we're looking at consumer behavior
because you know you're mentoring the
metaverse and it's a fascinating subject
i've been fascinated going through
sandbox and experiencing some of those
real estate properties and trying to
envision you know how these properties
may one day be worth
similar amounts to to real real estate
but obviously constructed very
differently
the shifting consumer behavior is this
shaping the way that people are already
thinking through buildings whether it be
through
communal living or or different things
that that society may be requesting is
this something that's you know really
deep already in real estate
it's not deep in real estate but it's
getting there
the the
id is like what we call today 15-minute
city things like that
where where you started
so so the concept is basically that
everything that you need
within the city will be in the 15
minutes walk from for where you live wow
so you'll be able to or to
work
shop
and
spend you know your leisure time all
together in just this
very narrow area and and even you know
things like putting in the right gardens
uh where you live and things like that
so so these are concepts which are
now becoming more and more into a
i would say acceptable or or people are
looking for that people are looking for
the community
there are a there are several startups
to do it but even without startups you
you see neighborhoods that have a
neighborhood whatsapp
and they start doing things together and
and you know
so you even see that
it's it's becoming more and more
i would say a acceptable or or these
days that people
look for it while a few years back
people were more
you know i'm going to be behind my walls
and and my house and i don't want to
know what's going on out there
i think this is this is definitely going
to change
incredible and so you know
real estate
i i know how i got into software and i i
can imagine
how one may get into something like real
estate but but not just from you know
from from specific projects but really
high level thinking today the country
manager for jll i believe the largest
company in the world that has something
to do with real real estate in general
with over 96 000 employees and you're
you're managing your
from israel
what how did how did you get into real
estate what was it about real estate
that that fascinated you enough that you
know today you're both with jlo but
you're also lecturing about it at iphone
university funny enough it was by chance
my background is actually from from the
infrastructure side i worked on a
mainly on on desalination water projects
worked all over the place
all over the world whether it's in
australia in china spain in the states
um
and then when jll basically we decided
to start building the operations in
israel and they reached out to me i
thought it's an amazing opportunity
because of an organization this size
and and you know we always treat
ourselves here as a startup within a
large corporate
because because we are we are building
here a team you know we grew
a
i think last two years two and a half
years from about 50 people to over 200
people and and
it we were working you know
both with corporate clients but also
with local clients and you work with
high tech and
we are working with a lot of startups
doing pocs pilots and stuff like that
just to see where and how can we
put more technology
to our clients and and to ourselves by
the way we also like to invest in in the
right a
technologies
uh that we think are gonna make an
impact
one of the things that i've been
thinking about is you know looking at
me as an example and i'm thinking okay
well i'm going to want to build a
company
and at one point i'm thinking there it
seems like there's such a big barrier
for me as an engineer as a software
engineer and you know part of the
startup ecosystem to understand even
what are the different opportunities
they have with something as complicated
as old-fashioned and traditional as real
estate so what are some things that that
i or my friends can do
to get acquainted better with this
industry and understand how we can
leverage you know the new technologies
we have with us
to change the way real estate is being
conducted
so a friend of mine keeps saying that
people who really made the change in the
in in the real estate industry never
came from within the real estate
industry
and and for any entrepreneur who wants
to to go in i would just say ask people
love to talk about what they do really
all you have to do is ask and you'll be
surprised how much people would love to
sit down with you and tell you what
they're doing
so
and anyone who wants to go into
into real estate or has this amazing
idea
and i see tons by the way of software
engineers coming in into this and having
these amazing ideas and and fresh look
on stuff and it's it's really important
uh
all they have to do is just come in and
say this is you know we want to do it
and and i think they'll find a lot of
people willing to help them there
thank you very very much and it was
fascinating for me to hear
and you know with your expertise and
your your deep understanding and one of
the things that i'm leaving here
is understanding the complexity and
understanding that it's a that it's a
long process but the leading with
excitement that uh you know there were
have some some exciting things up ahead
and
i think that you know i've been waiting
to understand i'm trying to wrap my head
around why why aren't we seeing the same
pace the same growth as i'm staying in
the soft world in real estate and i'm
you know 20 minutes is not nearly enough
to begin understanding this but but but
at least
the curiosity is there so i i'm gonna be
picking your brain quite a bit more so
thank you for that
sure my pleasure and you know what i'll
i'll give you another thing to think
about
uh
today people use brokers
think about how 10 15 years ago people
use travel
agencies
right and think how reasonable that is
really seem to you that people use
brokers today to go and buy a house
and how it's going to look in 10 or 15
years from now
100 100 percent
thank you very much you're welcome my
pleasure
bye-bye
bye
[Music]